food is my absolute favorite way to
explore my heritage esopes son mis
favoritos hey everyone i'm diana and i'm
here with my mom
hola
and today we're making mexican sopas
mexican sopas are a traditional mexican
recipe they're basically a handmade
tortilla stacked with a bunch of
different toppings and they're really
delicious one of the most amazing things
for me is the way in which my mom is
able to just kind of fill out all the
measurements without actually measuring
every single ingredient for example when
it comes to making the dough my mom's
looking for a certain softness and
consistency and basically when she gets
to that elasticity with the dough she's
able to make the sockets
california chilies are not necessarily
really spicy especially when you scoop
out all the seeds from inside but they
bring out a really good flavor to the
coating of the soap
so when it comes to boiling the tomatoes
you want to look out for the skin of the
tomato to start peeling off and once
they're doing that it's time to turn
down the fire and pull them out the
tomato dressing is actually one of the
most simple types of dressings that you
could make the simplicity of it allows
the tomato flavors to really stand out
basically i grew up in mexico for a few
years while i was very young even though
i live in the u.s i am very much very
mexican my mom continues to instill in
us a lot of the traditions through food
or through our culture in general that
she grew up with and to some extent that
i grew up with i'm not the best cook but
my mom is and so i really like to take
tips from her but also be in the kitchen
with her and just kind of like seeing
all the crazy things that she does i
really value my heritage i think that it
has taught me so much not only about
food but about so many other traditions
i like my steak to be cut down to just
small square pieces and that's always
how my mom has done it it just makes it
easier to eat you want to make sure that
you allow your sopas to cool off before
you dip them in the hot sauce and start
frying them because if you don't let
them chill out for at least an hour the
heat will disintegrate the dough i
basically grew up eating sopas and a ton
of other classic mexican recipes soap is
for sure one of my all-time favorite i
may be biased but i think my mom makes
the best mexican sopas ever me gusta la
cosina mexicana porque loca
and now the best part about sopas is
that you could add as much toppings as
you like obviously i like to put as much
as possible
[Music]
oh yes
you